who would you like to see devin fight
next tier field
tia fijo all right so you heard what
mike just said he has no no [ __ ] i
ain't crying
no no that's not his [ __ ] name i
[ __ ] up his name
mr lopez you heard what the champ said
they running scared
i did not close no yeah i call this a
little bit they're trying to [ __ ]
the words in my mouth you said it mike
no i did not
i did not you [ __ ]
[Music]
welcome to hot boxing with mike tyson
i'm zab judah and i'm here with
mike tyson and i'm here with devin the
dream haney
and the drizzy and i'm here with vh the
great
oh we got a bunch of big time names here
now this is gonna be so interesting this
is fun
this is fun the champ is in the building
wow
what's brother what's going on man good
i'm happy to be here you know but what
what you got on the horizon you know i
called you because of the situation
it's a lot of big fights uh to be made
i'm
one of the ones that's calling for these
top guys i'm the ones that call them for
these fights
i don't see nobody calling for me but
i'm the main one calling for
these fighters well the gentleman we had
here
tfo theme lopez
said he would kick your ass and that's
why i got you on the phone
yeah but he just said that in the
interview but in reality when it when it
come to
actually putting a fight together that's
not the case at all
listen if evan did something you would
have probably knew his name
he's around here acting like he's the
king of something and he's the king of
nothing
this is the best [ __ ] in the
world right now and the most feared man
in boxing similar to both what you your
two gentlemen experience
uh coming up everybody say everything
but they
they don't say that they want to fight
not next but right now
he's asking for everybody right now mike
i mean you got to know how this [ __ ]
feels
you died both too 100 the pinnacle
of this sport and everybody plays the
politics but now i know the game
everybody talks [ __ ] but nobody
everybody plays the public
but now with social media you know
fighters like him are
able to have companies he started he's
young he owns his own company
and he's able to dictate and negotiate
fights on his terms
it's very it's such a unique situation
in being a millennial
but the more that uh his career goes
that you know these are times that
will define his legacy being able to get
in the fight
at the right time well this is the time
that you know i have to agree with you
and this is the time where i see more
fighters even like
like floyd i have to give them this
they're more enterprise um
orientated than we were when we were
fighting right you know so much
enterprise or and they have connection
that we we had connections but we were
playing games right
yeah we were playing no you were
trailblazing you guys were all
trailblazing you know
and and you got and it's not even a
blueprint it's a green print
you know and you said it time and time
again it was you know we said shout out
to you who
you told javonte davis to uh take the
opportunity as a
as a fighter to reach out to another
fighter put the lawyers together and
negotiate
and you know for my and you know from my
perspective that's a that's the way to
go
so let's get right to it who do you want
man i want the i want so many of them is
tia female lopez it's ryan garcia and
it's tank davis
and then it's me they miss them is the
top four dogs in the lightweight
division and in boxing
and them is the fights to be made either
or whichever whichever one the main
fight that i want is
to female because that's for all the
belts
that'll be the real undisputed king ryan
garcia that's a that would be a huge
fight of course
tank davis that would be a huge fight of
course but i want all the belts right
now
and the point of my career i'm making
great money but
right now i'm chasing the belt so pops
what's what's the hold up with these
with these fights that's being made with
motives
promoters are trying to extort on the
side
i wouldn't even say it's the promoters i
think that it's the fighters because
then they should be stripped exactly i
agree
that goes back to the organizations who
have loyalty certain loyalties
or certain biases towards certain
fighters
and then allow them to but then again
with social media
and platforms like you uh you have here
and voices like zap
you know that stripping [ __ ] and and
that uh uh
under uh you know not giving the
fighters they're just like mike mccallum
who was a hell of a fighter and one of
our trainers
who said he said to me says uh my nobody
wanted to fight mike
now see but mike told me he says don't
let him do he says don't let
them do what they did to him right
so so that's why i campaign i i you know
i do as much as i can
you know about him you know what i mean
just to let people know that he is the
baddest [ __ ] in the world right
it's at the point to where it's like
fighters don't even care about the belts
no more because
for example ryan garcia just fought a
title eliminator to fight me
to fight me for the world title and he
want to go fight somebody else he want
to go a different direction so it's like
this is the first time in history that
i'd ever been heard where two fighters
meaning luke campbell and ryan garcia
fight for a title eliminator
fight to go fight for the world title
and
he still don't want to shout at the
world title
i don't know what you know what what
rules should be made
for fighters can't avoid fighters and
have to fight their mandatory
what rule has to be made well that would
be the same as if when you
when you had the opportunity to fight
bourbon you know
and you decided to go for someone else
or zab when you had the top
opportunity to be a world champion as a
mandatory when devon had an opportunity
to be a mandatory
it was against what was to be considered
the best one of the best fighters in the
world
in lomachenko and devin stepped up to to
the opportunity
and unfortunately for the people as fans
didn't get a chance to see devin fight
lomachenko right
because lomachenko decided to uh to opt
and become a franchise champion
the people don't understand it but it's
it's a way of glorifying
uh a duck you know what i'm saying but
like i said you know the
platforms like this we get a chance to
tell our story well all that he went
through right now would you fight uh
uh what's his name uh the guy you just
mentioned loma lomanchenko
of course i think that that would have
been a perfect fight for me i've been
saying that
loma is beatable loma is beatable i kept
saying it over and over and over and
over again
and people wasn't listening people pull
up dms and show them show them
how you've been damned we've been and
loma
for forever i was what i'm saying but
even more than dm and like we didn't
reach out
plenty of times trying to make the fight
happen and
he didn't want to make it by half but
that's when the wbc made up a franchise
title not even a franchise built a
franchise title and that was
they elevated loma to be the franchise
champion
franchise champion and that's when i
fought for
fighters don't need no one well that's
why i said pull up the dms because as
a as a promoter and being one of the
youngest promoters in the game
with the belt the only thing you can do
is reach out
to the fighters that's the only thing he
can do as a as a businessman only the
import fighter can promote this himself
that's right you know other than that
he's working for somebody else so this
is what the dm's saying
my first dm was january 14th so mike he
know how to read the dm
we in the dm this is getting good now
pay-per-view baby i'm avail lyon i heard
lopez
is trying to back out of a fight
generate millions oh uh oh what else is
he supposed what else is he talking
about
in the fight the last thing he said was
i will keep in mind
i will keep it in mind you know what i'm
saying so
i was just a different kind of fighter i
would say saying yeah you keep my dick
in your mind
how do you do humiliate their mother
sister
obviously i didn't have no dignity when
it came to
fighting and [ __ ] with somebody's
head yeah it was a testament it's a
testament to a fighter
that you know like i always say you guys
paving the way and him
growing and maturing taking your taking
your advice
with the lomas of the world the tea of
females out of the world
and to be professional with them as much
as you possibly can
make it happen yeah you got to get your
chance to fight them a chance but fight
them
fighting with which with the most
interest you know you have
this is all right take care of your fam
this this right here is just a platform
to take care of your family that's all
fighting this
yeah but what i feel like is is so many
fights to be made out there that we need
to make these fights happen now because
you know pretty a couple years down the
line there's gonna be some new fighters
there's gonna be some more fighters what
i did when the guys were avoiding me i
just kept fighting kept shocked right
then that's right they weren't going to
do me like sugar
sugar atlanta was such a master and
he'll wait you out three four five years
you know what i mean you get slowed and
boom hit jump on you
unfortunately for them devon is younger
than everybody yeah that's good too but
it's not about ages it's about desire
exactly if he still has the same desire
then he's still right
i respect you know what it is because
too uh you know you know
you guys had opportunity and you guys
see me i kind of did the same kind of
thing
we went when it was time that i wanted
to go get the champion and i called the
champion out but he was going left on me
i went to four two three two three guys
and trashed them
to make the champion look at me to make
everybody go oh
zap is still here see but now now we got
so many internet thugs and
reporters that's be talking [ __ ] so now
it's like
oh i go fight somebody it's like i just
went and fought gamble now they don't
value gamboa but again
gambol fought tank and had a tough fight
with tank and i go in there and
i go in there and i don't get touched
and i was getting bored was washed out
you know always this gamble was down
dominated
so it's like in a way that he's never
been dominated before
respectfully tank had a couple black
eyes uh
terence crawford got buzzed you know
what i mean and champ was looking just
like
like he's looking at the end of the
fight and you know it's
like you said it's about feeding your
family so the first thing that we we
learned coming into it is to hit and not
get hit
right yeah that's defense
boxing i if i was to go in there and i
was to go in
and knock a guy out cold but i took some
punches and i took a beating
in the process i wouldn't be happy i
wouldn't be happy with that performance
if i went in there
and i and i just boxed clean didn't get
touched didn't get hit
clean and hit hit him multiple times
that's a perfect performance for me
i've been around devon from day one and
that's if i see devon start getting hit
back and forth and punching and slugging
that's not devon style devin ain't
never hit that's not his style he's a
clean boxer
you know i mean stick to your script
don't let nobody tell you oh
that's this or that man this got you to
the top that's why you chamber the world
game of the game that's
it win keep winning it's called the
fighting because
that's what would be called fighting
right that fight it's called fighting
just from a slang
yeah there's so much more than fighting
this boxing baby's the skill
that's the heart
that's why they hate you your skill for
sure
all right i'm still paying the bills man
i watched you um
i watched you sparring with of course
stevenson
yeah that's what you got to do with
those fast guys just keep on hitting
them there all day
yeah devin i love when devon be
aggressive
i'll get aggressive you know what i'm
talking about
yeah yeah see that that's that's what's
different between me and these other
fighters that
i could do it all i can box i can bang i
can
i'm but in the process i'm still smart i
still got
ring iq i didn't been in there with the
best or the best of the best
and i haven't been around the best like
you like zab
and so that's just what separates from
these guys
i respect that i'm always young you feel
like being around lately it's like just
being around them until my friend y'all
was around i had pictures with him
showing off and stuff
yeah i mean that's that's and that's you
you guys
are heroes to the community man because
those are times that it just gives
like devin we were there and just gives
us that much more it gave us that much
more motivation just
being around and seeing you guys seeing
the cars and
seeing the commitment that you guys had
you know to the sport and when i say
that
you know people reporters and you know
give [ __ ] to the fighters but
to be a fighter and to get in the ring
man takes a hell of a commitment man
you know just to show up on fight
[ __ ] night you dig what i'm saying
you have to want to either side on both
[ __ ] sides
big underrated and i don't know i know
people
privately would agree to me but they
wouldn't say it publicly it's a form of
insanity
some it's a small form of insanity
involved with that mm-hmm
how do you go into in the ring with a
guy you don't even know
oh yeah never did nothing to you and
then you want to kill him like he
[ __ ] attacked your family or
something that's called discipline
yes and that's what people don't
understand this is our art
you know there's no emotion involved
but it causes so much emotions that
people watching it
would you consider a genius like did you
consider at
when you were in your sport as a genius
was it anything that you felt
genius like or you were you i felt
divine
divine yeah i thought i was the god from
war and god placed me here
and do this and represent him and i feel
like that too though
i was designed to do this and i believe
and i believe the reason i lost god was
jealous of me because i was getting too
famous and big and he had to put me in
my place
i was a sick dude when i was fighting
man i was really sick
i believed in the mythology and all that
[ __ ] i used
them i just used that as my ammunition
and my inspiration to fight
absolutely never been beat word up i've
been punished
never been beat and not by a human
like they say jordan he when he would
have games he would try to like
make up reasons to like all right i
might go for 60 because
uh a reporter said this about me or he
would like make up reasons to
go in there and play even harder do you
can you
see how old are you twenty-two who
believe this
time when you get older you realize how
fragile the human mind is
and how gentle our security is and
how insecure him the human mind is but
it's so powerful it runs the world but
it's so
it's such afraid of itself what is it
afraid of
that's what i never understood what is
the consciousness afraid of
that doesn't allow it to reach its
highest potential
now that's just nice yeah
but but they still that's what i mean
it's still champions of 22 years old and
stuff
and they have them you think it's just i
wish i was i'm the youngest champion
since you
um how do you handle that man it was
just
too much going on man i just always
wanted to be
the guy from the neighborhood that
nobody [ __ ] with not because he could
fight but he could fight
but he was a cool [ __ ] he could wear
his jewelry in his clothes and nobody
[ __ ] with them
that was my journey that's what i wanted
to be
[Music]
that's what happened to me well i mean
you know this is what happens to me well
legend has it and
and you've been open about it and that's
why i say just
meeting you and then your story because
the legend has it is that
you have all the talent in the world and
the one thing was was
drugs or drinking or partying or
something like that so
we took that and then with being with
floyd and
floyd being in the in there and
obviously him saying he doesn't drink or
smoke
and devin wrote with that that he was
like you know you can have all the
[ __ ] the big houses the
cars and [ __ ] but you just stick to your
craft don't smoke or drink
and that was pretty much the blueprint
from or the green print from what you
said
you know from what we heard right there
yeah i mean you know i don't
i see you guys like i said as heroes and
legends man who've paved the way
for the the new guys to come on come on
come along and revolutionize
what you guys have uh and what we gave
the way for independent um
enterprise yes sir um yes sir hundred
percent
the hp enterprise yeah i feel like me
being 22 years old and
i i got a rose race outside i got a
mansion i got
as much money as as i want right now
and and i could do what i want when i
want and i'm doing what i love
i'm blessed i feel like i'm blessed how
are you ever grateful
how are you dealing with it i don't know
i just feel like i just feel like i've
been
like i've been here and i've seen all
this coming like i knew that all this
was going to come i knew i was going to
have money i knew i was going to have
fame i knew i was going to have belts
i knew that this time was going to come
so it's like it's here
so listen it's easy you know you have
all that right
only reason people pay attention to you
because you're the champion exactly
and that's and that's that's what i love
people on the street with all that stuff
people don't even care about them
that'll make them even hate them more
yeah right yeah a thousand percent
you're the champion that's different and
and that's what makes that
big time different that's what made me
work so hard to continue to
stay the champ and you know get even
more i want all the belts i want
it's not only about money it's not only
about fame you know it's about legacy
and i want
i want my name to live live on much
longer than i ever will i want my name
to be mentioned with the greats
and disputes it will be on this beauty
you know um
it's up next that's good that's not
harder to make it's harder to be
with the good that's what great
you know that right now like elaborate
on that more you know um
i met a lot of great people but they
weren't good
um you know that i mean they were great
everybody bowed down but
they had good heart they were
compassionate and [ __ ]
yeah yeah for sure
wow oh no you got to get out and get it
man you know what i'm saying
and and take every day as a blessing
because it's a present you know
and work from where you are you know
what i'm saying like hundred percent
yeah
from you are like you know to to see you
and i
i say to watch you want to see you with
your daughter on the on the tennis court
and [ __ ]
remember yeah you're right looking out
your window right right and then to see
you out there
and then i was like whoa i was like man
because you you know you hear [ __ ] you
hear the stories and [ __ ] like that like
you all
[ __ ] partying but no but listen it
was like five or six yeah but listen
and no one my wife has said who's that
his son's gonna be world champion so
yes sir just like he's becoming world
champion i'm preparing her to be world
champion right yes sir
and that's what he's doing same thing
that's why i say the green print that
you've
you know you've maintained resiliency
and and through through the whole thing
you know
and been example for your kids to be to
be to be better
you know my kids are better than me now
great right now my kids are better than
me you know
because um at my daughter she's 12 i'm
locked up at 12.
i ain't that so my daughter 12 i'm
locked up at 12. right wow
and she's the smart ass at 12. spoils
have everything bless you yeah i can i
used to rob children like that
that's now i raise children like that
crazy yeah life is great you had him
boxing a little bit for a while do you
still
no he just was hitting the mitts and
stuff you know
i don't know these these guys sometimes
don't understand what fighting is
fighting this commitment fighting the
sacrifice
yeah a lot of sacrifices no how you know
you know i'm not saying this
impossible how could you just say you
have to have it in your blood you just
want to be the best that's why i said
money is not that it
money's not going to help you become
champion the desire to be the best is
well see he had that design i know yeah
but
it was ironically the way we found out
or at least that i saw it was
we're on the football field and devin
was the running back
and he's he's like the best running back
in the league he gets like probably four
touchdowns or something a game and
the quarterback uh his father is a coach
and you know
so the quarterback gets a couple
touchdowns and you know what i mean
we're supposed to go home happy
but devon wants the ball all the time
right he wants the ball all the time
devon scorpio scorpio
so he wanted the ball that's right
he wanted to he want the ball all the
time now which i know he was competitive
right
but at the same time when he was at
school he went to school
he was fighting right so he's fighting
and then now you know in our community
or whatever we
i got to go up to the school man me
having to go up to the school in the
middle of the day
you know and especially if i didn't
blazed
right it's [ __ ] like what the hell
what the hell
right they were talking about that right
so the principal is looking at me like a
like dead in my eyes like what's going
on in the house
i said devin what happened he said the
kid was about to hit me
i said oh you wasn't supposed to say
that right now in front of the
you know but you want to you want your
kid to not get hit so you say if
somebody's about to hit you
then you hit them right right so we we
left out of there always throw the first
punch that's why we threw the first
punch so yeah that's why he was so much
i was in trouble
huh i said that's a must yeah yeah so
you're that too
brown's gonna throw the first first
punch that's a must yeah you gotta
swing first you can see it's gonna be a
fight through the first punch
yeah yeah yeah so so we left out of
there and i looked over at him i said
man
you know you you playing games man you
know the kid
was just talking right and i said you
know you you know
you think you know how to just fight
with everybody so i'm gonna take you to
the gym
right unbeknown to me you can't just
spar
the first day what is the chances i'm
gonna find a kid for him to spar now
what i know
with devin so we take him to the gym but
it's a kid there
that uh he's doing like some karate and
the
you know but now he's doing the stand-up
boxing so he's moonlighting between the
two right right right
and so devin comes into you know we take
him in the gym
and i whisper to the coach and the coach
looks at me like
he got some fresh meat right a little
kid his first day
i'm like so you know he puts on the
thing and it's derek harmon if you guys
ever want to ask the question derek
harmon
former i don't know if derek was ever a
champion he fought i don't think he ever
became champion right he's a good tough
fighter he's a good tough fighter he was
the first he works over at top rank he
was
he was devin's first trainer that day at
that particular gym
they said yeah spar i said okay so they
lace devin up
and the kid you know i never forget
because the kid had on some little like
little velcro
shoes that little kids wear so don't
they don't have to parents don't have to
tie their shoes up
they have got on there knocked the kid
out of the shoes man
promised you knocked the kid out of
shoes i was like oh what we left the
football field and it's the first day
first first day i said what the [ __ ]
right after
he's you know now dev wants to go do his
normal [ __ ] get some [ __ ] you know
whatever
go to the store get a juice get some
candy candy yeah right right right
and then derek whispers to me says he
says the kids are natural
some people are just that with this
great fighters right he said he's a
natural okay tell me this
and what a few kevin didn't like that at
what age was devin when
you knew i this is it stop my day job
focus on my boy cause this is gonna be
the one right here
uh probably when we got when we got a
gym when he got his own gym
you guys yeah that was like [ __ ] what
how old were you
i don't know little little how old was i
hey lilo
i was i was deaf how old were you you
got it
he was younger than that nope i probably
like 10. i'm probably like 10
10. yeah cause he because he turned out
i mean
he did this first started at richard
still
no no that wasn't my first one my first
time her first first one's at richard
steele yeah his first one was like
richard still
then he got a chance to host yeah well i
tell you i remember i remember one time
we got in the car and we went to
san diego so tonight uh yeah
uh not arizona arizona arizona arizona
yeah yeah yeah
and uh it was it was a crazy fun it was
like it was me and you
and and tim marshall and marshall and
that was it and we had to fight like we
came to a town where they had
it's like they we thought they guys that
they grew up and the whole gym was
against
us the whole town was looking at us like
this yeah so we're standing there you
know
i was that judah so everybody knew i was
so that was cool and looking like who
you got i was like
what i got my girlfriend he bought the
what we're saying out in here what
inside let's go so devon fought this kid
like a popular kid the killer
yeah hey i still know his name today to
this day he was popular kid came in with
a big sombrero on
and they had i was like all right don't
don't
worry about none of that go in there
just stay good keep boxing and just box
them down
hi you know they had a little creepy
voice
i got it i got it yo he wore this
kid yo the whole building was like this
yep yo how old is he how he's saying how
old is he
how old are he his a
a lot of tournaments with me and that
was happening
[ __ ] again i would love to do that
yeah i would love to hey used to be
crazy because
i remember when i used that when i was a
kid that's the best part of my life
going on tournaments and your jacket
yeah
your medals and your hats between them
i've always seen epic moments you know
and one of the times
over at the hit factory when you guys
sparred at that time
yeah yeah yeah yeah ready yeah yeah
he was jealous i said you know what it
was i like his
the way he loved it his enthusiasm to
how he
paid attention to like what was going on
was different you know because we had
other guys in there kids in that timing
them
they were running around doing this
doing that playing with their playing
but devin was like this
student and i said question because that
that's what i tell people
i tell people to this day nobody hit me
hard as abs to hit me
man hit me with a body shot so hard it
was an uppercut to the body
i wanted to drop my first party shot i
ever got hit when i went down in life i
know when i first started boxing
yeah yeah i went down make no mistake
about it you know
the greats the legends you guys did you
know
did it the right way you know you didn't
coddle him you didn't baby him
you know what i mean he got to go in
there and go get it you know what i'm
saying
and uh you know it's times of course and
even with the young fighters who
who look to want to get fighters to come
on and help them get famous before
they're famous you know we've we've been
through that part and it's better for a
fighter
to to uh stay stay the course you know
what i mean
you know do his program you know what i
mean verse trying to get people to come
on board
and to cheer for him people gonna come
you know what i'm saying i've watched
devon state of course
and now i see that you know he's getting
some uh some just do
and you just like you said before stay
being a champion
but that's why i went when young
fighters come and they want to spark me
and they want to be
around me and everything i don't go easy
on them oh you can't no
if you if you really if you really want
to you know make it to the top you got
to go through what i've been through
if you want to be around me you got to
go through what i've been through you
got to run the channel
wait listen i was even before i was here
my mentor customization
do you tell the guys to pro do your best
i know he's a kid but do your best
i spoil but like i'm i'm fighting yeah
yeah me trying to kill you
now you guys are you guys gonna say that
right
now on boxing that because people say
that you're not supposed to and i've
watched you spar many times
you know what i mean and paying them too
you're gonna pay a person you're gonna
come in there or you're gonna need
what's the name
my job is this my i'm the boss
and your job is to kick your boss ass
and if you don't kick your butt's ass
you're fired and i got it from him
ain't that something you don't kick your
boss ass your fight you ever have a job
like that i think one thing
one thing my dad installed me and
starting since i was a young kid was
what you do in the gym is what you're
gonna do in the fight yeah
so if you could be bullshitting in the
gym you'd be bushing and sparring you
want to play and sparring
you don't go in the fight and do the
same thing yeah got to get that respect
out the gate
fighting is only about being smart this
is a smart man game this ain't no tough
guy sport
right tough guys go talk funny at the
end of the day this is a thank you man's
game
only a thinking man is the best in this
game well out of 25 fights i don't think
he's lost a round
you know what i mean so in terms of you
know and
and and we're getting paid he's he
happens to be out of his
out of his group he's the highest paid
in the lightweight division you know but
politics
and the platform like a big platform
like espn
will create a narrative like maybe this
fight shouldn't happen
but fortunately for us you know we're
working hard
we we're keeping our nose to the ground
and we keep screaming for
these big fights to happen i got one for
you
what's your biggest worry with devin
um overall everything about life life
you're watching everything happen with
oh the biggest worry that's easy
is is getting caught up in somebody
else's dream
uh verse stand on yours on his you know
he spent so much time
on his dream you meet people that come
along and now
they have a dream you have a you have a
wife she has a dream you have
these other friends you met they have a
dream and and the difference talk to him
right now look at him talk to him about
that
i talk to him
[Laughter]
i needed somebody to tell me if you know
when i was going through my [ __ ]
yeah but you know but he knows right no
i definitely hundred percent that's why
i focus on
but but what you have to do is validate
as a champion
that he don't owe nobody's [ __ ] no you
see what i'm saying
you don't hold on you don't know if we
know what you did inside this
like some people feel survival guilt you
know i mean
they said why do i got all of this they
don't understand that it's sort of thing
about god from the haptics they think
you know because it's because it comes
across easy then all he has to do is
have fun
and all this comes to him but he has to
know with the different
um energy that gave you this people
think i'm a weird dude but you know
you're special you're touched
no i asked them just like i'm sure that
you went through and you went through
like every other dad i say i i look over
at him i said hey
where did all these people come from i
said who the [ __ ] is he
she all these people just the other day
it was you know it was
you but it's his journey it's his test
just like it was um
the prophets and all those guys tests
many years ago
he's being tested by life right yeah
this is one big school the world is one
big school
i would hope that he of course would
stay focused on his dream
and not of the course of his dream
because he's
meeting people he has money and all the
stuff
that he tends to want to because he's a
good person
he wants to help their dream he wants to
be a part of the dream so now he
adds people on to this to this thing and
i think it makes it harder
it makes it harder on you because he has
something that he's been seeing for a
long time
and he's starting to see it and
sometimes you'll get derailed
by meeting other people and [ __ ]
doing some other [ __ ] mike
life teaches life teaches him what his
parents and humans can't
you know right right right yeah oh 100
he get charged up
and as soon as it happened i said just
like you i said what'd you do
i saw the game then charge yo
quick you know the game turns him out
you know he wants to be a champ
something happened he saw somebody
or you watched them somebody saw it
because i saw sugar ray linden and
somebody i've seen made me want to do
this [ __ ]
well i'll leave with the first one but i
saw sugar ray and duran i said [ __ ] i
know i want to do it now
hell yeah who was the who was the first
person you seen in the gym
that really inspired you um jose benitez
need this i would definitely we
who would you would you say zap for sure
is that yeah
yeah because like in the gym zad was
somebody that i could touch somebody i
could go talk to that i could call
anytime i wanted to so like like he
inspired me a lot
and he was champ so it was like i was
able to just
like see this [ __ ] before it even
happened so i would think no always
thankful for that another story um
in 1986 one day i was you know i was
hanging out but i knew his fault
it was supposed to mean come on come on
kiss me i followed in my car and i met
zab
when i was 20. how old were you back
then when i was twenty
eight yeah i mean when he woke him up
yeah it was upper there yeah that's what
he talked about he made an album
like four in the morning they ran each
other and we know we was home sleep
and my dad came in and wake up wake up
wake up we get up
coming in here we're saying like oh
we're in trouble i haven't having god
mike was standing right there he was
like i thought he was dreaming
like tyson tyson oh
it was crazy how did that impact you
though it's crazy like so
what we went to the gym that day that
uses in the gym we were doing white
movies
boom mike always has when you came to
when you came to our gym
that was just crazy because you came in
there and we i mean
we we went off of just inspiration and
motivation
by that day for i don't know how long
you know what i'm saying yeah
just that you even just came to the gym
and this was after you were
you know you know yeah i understand what
that would mean by having somebody
around you that you could see
and touch and talk to it was the same
way for me i was going to i had you know
michael's there i had prenatal whitaker
you know i'm i'm every i'm talking to
these dudes and like pernell was pound
for pound the best in the world
and i'm like yo pete what's up with that
he telling me yeah do this do that do
that i'm like
i run into my own champ
[Music]
and other people are looking at me like
hell you know brunette whatever
like yeah it's mother smile me like you
know my favorite i'm like yeah
that's big bro hey like damn
it's crazy because i remember going to
fights with zab and
the like fans mobbing him and you know
me thinking like damn like oh one day
that they don't mind me like that
and now i go to the fights and you can't
regardless yeah
troy thank you brother
now i need a rag i need like a wash rag
i love it did they edit that out or
today
no [ __ ] this is wow baby
now i thought they were going to take
away my dignity once we got incorporated
but this is
still me doing what i wanted another
testament to you being a boss man
you know trailblazing this this whole
cannabis [ __ ] through man you know what
i'm saying
it's all about it's all about surviving
everything you know
like we lost a lot like we lost our
brother zip should be
part of the zip this should be zip stuff
right here yeah you know zip was a bad
[ __ ] wasn't he
the best all right the best wonderful
greatest one one of the greatest best
move
[ __ ] zip took uh you remember well yeah
over mike's house i remember mike told
me the shadow box he said let me see
what you got
right but i but i was young so
i was nervous i i didn't want a shadow
box just because i was nervous i never
i never met mike tyson before so it was
like damn mike tyson wants me to shadow
box
and so like i just was standing there
with my hands in my pockets
mike was like come on man shout out
bucks let me see what you got but
i never did it and i thought about it
it's stuck in the back of my head like
damn
i should have just shadow box i should
just show them what i had
but i was nervous and you know i was
starstruck but
you know it's crazy that how life worked
out oh
life we don't even know nothing about
life
nothing we see you now yeah yeah
now now we could now we could play my
highlights or some some you know now you
can see me on tv
exactly so mike i've never asked you and
and
then it's a two-part question with that
but uh
you don't speak much about your your
father you haven't your father
or when was your father in your life or
you know before a custom model
a peep game i just i just finished i'm
making the um
well i finished just paying for a
beautiful headstone for him yeah
probably a month ago yeah good good
bless you yeah
that's that's that's the beauty in me
right then even with zap
as you and abba going to heights of
being a world champion
champion and everything did it ever come
a time that someone
was trying to pit or come come between
you and abba
and what did y'all do to stay stay
strong through it all because i see you
guys still
um out the gate you know
you know my father anybody i know my
father they know how he is my father you
know
he's an alpha male male you know and out
the gate
from young upon winning golden gloves
and doing all this stuff he talked about
the gate he said it's always going to be
separation the higher we go
somebody gonna try to flip in here and
say hey don't worry about him come over
here with us and do this because you
just tell me the same thing
yeah make it always come between
somebody that's what you love
cousins would say the same thing to me
always worrying about somebody stealing
me i think
he said people would offer you stuff
because he wanted to buy me
a cadillac a car and i said i don't want
to call i just want to be here with you
to know people will
give you things that may take you away i
said well i'm not going away this is my
i never understood that why am i going
somewhere i'm staying here with you
but he said um i didn't understand what
he was trying to do but i understand now
that people's gonna give you money and
take you away from this story but
take me away i'm not gonna take me away
i didn't think i was worth anything but
he saw the future
he said yeah what age was 15 when i
first met cuz
yeah 12 13. yeah
very formidable years yeah i got him out
of as soon as i got out of um
jail institution i went over i started
living with him
abu was different i would do stuff and
then like you know like
you know like we'd be with him and some
[ __ ] poppies he had a family though
father street it was scary though
because he would do street [ __ ] and then
get back in the car
like no no this is just yeah this is
true
he says he said his father was a
[ __ ]
i swear y'all he would do street stuff
right get back in the car we all in the
car he like
i know we're together forever right
that's it that that's the contract hey
look at you you know we're together
forever right like
yeah so he never had to say
don't let yo he would just tell us
people are going to try
right but you already know what time it
is you know we didn't
we just watched him come in the car how
many brothers you got it's like it's 10
of us
like 10 of us so you know and he would
tell us like you know we together
forever baby
it's us to the end of the time right
listen we look at him like
right yeah how crazy you know you're in
the tournament you're talking to
somebody
with some i don't know somebody else's
coach or something just watching
that was a great fight you have
customers go over and say hey excuse me
sir do you know this
kid what are you talking to thinking
everybody's gonna steal me from them
right
so i did the opposite because i always
thought
somebody was gonna steal me you know
what i'm saying and he had to be
prepared
so if they stole me then what would my
king do
and and you know what i mean in my
absence so
you know that's that's the cycle of life
because i think as a parent
you you try to prepare your kids to do
better than you
to take care of you god willing just
like you took care of them
and and and should they don't because
you understand that you know
in life it's all kind of different
people as parents
that's just what we do that's just what
you do as you choose once you choose to
be a [ __ ] parent
yeah that's the responsibility of right
and that's why i seen you out at five in
the morning [ __ ] world champion
you know uh bigger than life in the mist
rain watching your daughter when nobody
else would motivating and talking to her
man and i
you know that was one other time she's
gone i'm trying to prepare her
prepare her right exactly and so with
with that
with that we started early giving him
giving him what the people were going to
give him anyway because he's destined
for it
and and having him prepared in a way
that
he has has the millions but he's ready
for tens of millions
no i think i think he's already prepared
yes he's always um still determined to
fight
right now exactly because you know that
wasn't part of the bargain
right when i knew that he when they said
that he was a nacho and he had talent
and he got a chance to meet
the greats and you know the mike
mccallums and you and
and eddie mustafa's and every everybody
then
him being successful or being rich
wasn't part of the bargain
that was the part that i was going to do
was going to be determined that
you know he wasn't going to get back
door from from from nobody
he was going to have somebody that was
going to represent him and represent his
word
and not the word that that was
compromised by whatever position
the manager was in you know just you
know great job also and do it right
that's one thing i always say that i
admired about you because uh
i watch you from day one and you always
even though you was the top trainer you
went and got other professional opinions
and stood right there and
and got the information then you moved
on to another train and got more
information and you was never
afraid to say there's a kid over we was
living in vegas but he said the kid over
in philly that's the number one i i i he
must be the
he was like what pack the call everybody
we going to philly to find this guy i
had to watch him they get they get in
the sprinters
and pull up and philly go in the gym and
with leroy jones at
we looking for leroy jones here hey how
you doing
we're the same way we want a spa like i
i seen this and i was like wow
this is amazing well you know you know
the reason why i did that was
obviously you were gonna get good work
but what what i learned getting older
was it was nobody
tougher than nobody it's no street or
city that got no [ __ ] that's tougher
than no other [ __ ]
and he had to know that he had to know
that it was a skill
that he developed and crafted yeah you
seen him saying so once
we went to brooklyn we went to newark
seen shakur many times
shakur been a bad [ __ ] all his
life so so we went knocked on his door
you know we went and of course knocked
on javonte davis
door first time in baltimore at his gym
the second time is when they sparred at
floyd's gym
you see what i'm saying so it was about
you know of course we came up to
uh to to the gym up to abbas and you
know what i'm saying
and did our thing in new york you know
him we went to london
you know and i'm sure like with your
daughter right you you want her to play
around the biggest people so when that
moment comes that
she's it's just it's just another day so
fighting someone that was a top dog in
the united states
for devon that didn't mean anything even
as a kid
because we went to knock on their door
we wouldn't and and then of course got
good work from all of them and got
something to work on yeah for me you're
really familiar with them from sparring
with them
right when i was coming up i normally
bothered everybody that was the top guy
exactly and that's why i feel like i
know
all the guys that's where some somebody
can't just come out to
blue and say oh i'm the best i'm this
i'm that because
nah brother i would know you all right
give me a secret then because everybody
what guy that you sparred that you
thought was really bad and then
you knew once you once you did well with
him and sparring
you know you felt you was you was ready
or or you know it might be two or three
guys but what god understand i don't
know um
whether carlos de leon um carla truth
william
a lot of yeah i don't know as a young
guy how was you when you started
i did um 15 15. yeah yeah
how about you okay uh for me
boxing with pernell box with purnell and
junior jones
junior was mean did he try to hurt you
in there yeah junior tried to hurt me
and he had a strong right hand but
he was he was good though he's a
brooklyn boy him
kevin kelly yeah tough guy
yeah jones was tough yeah these guys you
know come out of new york these guys you
had you had to go against
for me for me personally when i saw him
in the ring with you
you know what i'm saying because i knew
you wasn't going you wasn't going caught
on youtube
and when you came and told me you said
he ready because he read it you know
what i'm saying
and yeah and then even and that i don't
know because
like i said it was a compliment to mike
who said he saw
dev when he was 16 sparring shakur and
then when you
because he turned pro at 17 but you had
probably told me like when he was like
16
to cut him loose like i wouldn't turn
him
when you said he was ready you know what
i'm saying i kind of still
i remember devon like 11. he went to uh
tomorrow charleston his first march oh
my god
we're running we're going to was driving
up he said where we going
and you know up there you can see i said
look we're going to go we're going to
end up
all the way up there he said running
running
yeah we're going to run legendary mom
and that's when i knew devin was he
he was full he stayed with me the whole
time
he did not stop he stayed with me it was
cold i mean it was cold that day
he stayed with me the whole time all the
way up you know i was in top [ __ ] i was
going for a championship fight i think
he was fighting amir khan i want to see
you playing amir khan
yeah yo and he stayed with me the whole
time man we had we had a good and that's
why
i said cuz he ready i said he ready he
got that
because that run is no joke anybody
anybody
you can't just you can't just do that
just after all nice stuff
it's straight up to here like you start
like you start
and it's straight up ain't no [ __ ]
it's five miles straight up straight up
yeah oh it's the hot on there
the air is thin up there that shit's
crazy but i've seen i still
i still run that run to this day when i
train up for all my fights
mickey bass told me he said he said cuz
i had to have the ambulance come and get
he went up there one time that run he
had a heart attack yeah who
mickey bay when he was running uh mount
charleston i believe it i
i had my you know rest in peace my uncle
jimmy he was up there he got out y'all
know jimmy
jimmy got out and said i'm i'm running a
few miles with you
he started running nazi and they said
he's the way he's away oh oh he's there
what's up you're good you got the iii
pack it up pack it up pack it let's go
let's go let's go back down the hill
and by the time he got back down he
calmed down and he he was good but that
mountain up there the era super thing
yeah i've seen people get up there for
the first time i think they oh i'm in
top shape i could do this to do that
and get it it'll hurt the best stuff
lose it brother and lose it they don't
know where they at
they get the gas so yours miami is miami
because he just got up on miami as being
a spot to train like
like [ __ ] now what no no what do you
guys think he says
you lose hella weight i'm like he's like
because the humidity right so you lose
the weight good
and he says he wants to what do you
think what do you think with you guys
because you trained all around the world
right going to um if you go go to miami
you want to hang out there you need to
go to fort
not football but west palm beach and
trains i'm training
it's our way well yeah i can contest to
the story because i had a similar
situation i already
know i already i had a penthouse that
was staying in south beach i bought it
when i
had just won the title i had a uh a
condo that i was thinking
and my father didn't know i kept it away
from him oh so
so we was training we did our training
camp in hollywood florida
so every day you know when he first got
down and we had the hotels and
everything in hollywood the camp was set
up in hollywood but i had my crib
on south beach i never let anybody know
you know what i'm saying so you know a
couple weeks ago by now my dad like yeah
you know i'm so um
where do you live at i said you know i
lived up down the road man
i'm getting tired you know that's why i
got the driver and all that you know he
said yeah
come on i want to see it i want to see
what you what you living i'm like
yeah i got no we got a lot of stuff
today man listen let's do that tomorrow
another day said nah
let's do it today so i'm like all right
so i figured let me take him with me
let's detour yo let's put some sneakers
in the mall we go to the mall we do
other stuff
kill like two hours i'm like all right
you wanna go back to hotel you're like
nah
i wanna see your house i'm like god damn
so
here we go over to south beach he see my
house anyway
anyway long story short we get up to the
crib he'd walk around he lucky go
he opened the curtain he go damn this is
bad champ it's
bad i said yeah you know i say [ __ ] i
said yeah i bought the black curtain so
if i close it
look it's black in here get some good
sleep nothing yeah you can sleep on that
outside
i don't even get distracted by it he
said come on champ
he said there's no way in america you're
going to be champion over and stay chat
with the world living right here
i said why you say that he said open the
curtain he said look brother
it was mickey beach and opium right here
you can see all the clubs i was mad
i had to get out of this so i just tell
you how long was you saying there
i got away with it for about a good four
maybe maybe six months
i got away with a good six months
because my training camp started
at the end of my uh um end of the fifth
month yeah so i kind of got away with it
you know
i like it there because it's hot and you
could yeah yeah
yeah yeah
hey brother that's what makes you the
good godfather that you are with him
because you always
kept it real with him yeah i guess i do
yeah and you know
and it's a lot of
[Laughter]
he know one thing about it is i'm always
going to keep it real with him you know
i try i'm not gonna lie i tried it i did
it i got up i went running every day i
was running
but brother it's not the it's not the
run it's not the whole run dedication
it's the view the environment the lust
the temptation as you
the the more you run the more it grabs
you like oh my god look at how
i see but i take that as like motivation
your glasses yeah you do all that i know
i heard it all
i heard all of it i take it as
motivation like
yeah like oh
i take it as motivation like it makes me
want to run harder
when you see all these all these buying
females and see all these nice cars
it make you run harder [ __ ]
yeah well that's some people do that
when i see this that takes a
oh [ __ ] harder to run
get rid of this change my clothes and
get outside
that's just crazy champ is getting hot
y'all next time we're gonna bring you
we're gonna bring you some more strands
we got beverly hills exotics coming out
you know what i'm saying oh
time time now what are you talking about
now talking about some some
some good [ __ ] to smoke on that i didn't
smoke
champion chap got a few businesses too
though that he could plug though he got
weed
man cbd that's my cbd company
dream road transportation that's my uh
transportation company you know we
working on guys but
what you transferring [ __ ]
i transport yeah i trust i transfer cars
but you know we can transport anything
now you know
it's nice so beautiful it's still nice i
just transported my eyes
my roads race here right now so you know
that's what i used to do with my tigers
and [ __ ] i always have i bought a
truck for them i just got i just got
them i just got a monkey
mike yeah yeah why you want money to go
beat your [ __ ]
same thing about tigers that's not about
this about the energy it's all about
energy man i had the right i was lucky i
had the right cat
the other cat bit in my line bit me
ain't like me but i don't know if
i don't know if his monkey didn't bend
like with some like
like his former people like was white or
something because he got different
energy
but i mean he already got like an
attitude right
so i come and i and i i know i'm a
smooth guy i just try to
come with that [ __ ] i said no
i said no all right yeah that's it no
yeah no he don't mean he don't like when
you
monkey he don't like when you be moving
too fast around him he like to just you
know you got to be he messed with
he messed with champ you got to work
with your champ you don't mess with
nobody else
yeah they only have one yeah you just
got to work your way you got to give
them a tiger
one person really yeah yeah i thought i
was just going to rub his head or some
[ __ ] like that and
he wasn't he can't he wasn't having it
what kind of monkey how
that's a capuchin how big is it he's two
and he's like
probably like this big oh it's a
hellraiser they're talking a lot of
noise
i was in my closet the other day and all
i hear is screaming like ah
but i'm thinking it sounds like a human
what does it eat uh
watermelon a lot of fruits and
vegetables but his favorite is like
watermelon eat a lot of water like
how does his teeth look at things yeah
he got things he knows he's able to eat
the meat does he eat meat does he the
other monkey you know some monkeys eat
others
nah he don't you don't eat monkeys but
he eats like insects and so dig right
they start feeding that [ __ ]
meat i'm not coming over here
for real that [ __ ] yeah they're
different
i saw one i saw a monkey i don't know
the name i saw monkey grabbed another
monkey
broke his arm off and like and gave it
to the other mate
then they start eating them with things
right breaking them while he's alive you
start eating
nasty mike before you guys leave is that
who do you want to see
who would you like to see devin fight
next or not even next let's say now
well like shakur stevenson well he's at
1 30.
so next yeah next next order
of feel to your fijo yeah
yeah all right so you heard what mike
just said he has no no [ __ ] i ain't
crying
no no that's not his [ __ ] name i
[ __ ] up his name
mr lopez come on man be nice for this
guys not get away but now what about
ryan garcia
as a mandatory if if ryan garcia and
tank davis don't make that big fight
happen
do should ryan garcia fight devin hayden
absolutely absolutely
thank you brother thank you absolutely i
think i think a bigger fight is him in
tank
so let me ask you this thing if he was
wearing girls fighting next
he said he's fighting garcia no but if
he was ryan garcia would you fight devin
haney or would you fight tank
i'll fight tank because i want to get
trans
watched and get beat yeah chance i might
get beat with this guy i'm not gonna
fight
see he gonna look at this like from the
last fight even right before devonta
even knocked out
the last guy he was fighting he took
punishment he was getting out boxed
he was getting boxed you know i'm saying
it took him a minute to get inside to
catch the right shot to get him you know
what i'm saying
he's getting a box so ryan gosling look
at it wi-fi the boxer devin haney's a
boxer is it clean but he gonna put on a
hard smart fight for you
he figured maybe with tank he could get
lucky in in out boxing for 10 for
10 or 12 rounds whatever you know what i
mean which makes it an easier fight
that's what i would look at i was like
why would i fight devin definitely going
to box yeah moving around
y'all heard what the champ said they
running scared
and that's what they doing
i did not close yeah i call this a
little bit they're trying to [ __ ]
the words in my mouth you said it mike
no i did
not i did not oh you're [ __ ]
me i'm high they know like
i like the brooklyn boy but
[Music]
no mistake about it is you two dudes
ain't nothing to play with
and you're a historian in boxing and
you're a historian you
y'all don't [ __ ] around y'all not gonna
be on here with him
and telling him no [ __ ] that's why i
say that i respect totally about y'all
and you know off the record you know off
the record he's the baddest [ __ ]
and a bit in the business i've been
wanting these [ __ ] how long now
i've been wanting him i've been wanting
him so long as long as i've been
wondering
he was amateur i was like get ready you
have better get ready somebody's coming
and he's coming
you know people always say what does kid
devin henry you keep talking about watch
i kept my
i tell my wife i said baby don't you
remember that kid that's a little kid
he's world champion now champion really
right that just undermines everything
bob aaron has said
about devin no one knowing who devin is
and him being
it's ten other lightweights is better
than him and him needing a bigger fight
for it or bigger profile and i'm saying
bob my people we got we got
fans we got people that's going to buy
it and we also got haters
that's going that wants to come and
watch that i like mr aaron but you're
talking to a promoter
right right exactly that's his job his
job we got to let the world know that
part because devon's a promoter already
he's a he's a promoter as well but i
think he's a promoter that's more
transparent
than the other promoters because he's a
bad [ __ ] you understand what i'm
saying mike if
that [ __ ] wasn't if a
[ __ ] wasn't that good maybe he
would play the politics
that the other fighters is playing well
you have to understand the job of uh
promoting well the past promoters the
past promoters
these are [ __ ] no these are pimps and
they're taking the bad advantage of the
product because the product doesn't know
how how how expensive it is it doesn't
know it's value
so they mute that they milk the value
out of it until one day and sometimes it
never happened
he might wake up see that's the
difference between me and me between me
and a lot of other fighters is i knew my
value i
and that's why i didn't let no one just
try to buy me out or you know
try to you know take everything that
that i stood for and everything that i
believed in
i became my own promoter he was on show
box he did he's a show box alum
you know shout out to show box they did
it you know that's that platform that
you go to as a gladiator
that you you you willing to fight
anybody and everybody
you know as a young fighter espn was uh
no
yeah for my time right yeah friday night
friday night
tuesday night fights tuesday night
fights for yours so it was show box
devon went on show box as a promoter
coming from mexico
where he had ran up like 17 fights or
whatever and then had all
12 or 12 fights okay and then and then
went to uh
went to show box now man no i think you
did was
12 no 17 12 12. so that's why that's
what i love
he's a proud pop she's like what my boys
how did that feel to follow him
amazing yeah yeah i mean the truth asked
me was it exciting
yep i guess um in my white foreign
hustlers and players
they'd be drinking at my daughter's
match getting other people intimidated
oh god zip came with a different energy
different energy i love him from
excitement to hollywood
[Laughter]
i wanted him to see the success i eat
this oh he deserves to be
oh [ __ ] yeah he watching you watching
homie
yeah he was talking about them too yeah
sure he says i know
not the legend no joke man
so is it some kind of new york thing
that if you're from new york you just
got to ride with new york though
no no i mean i know it's a brooklyn
thing like that or well that's different
no that's that he said new york is there
so give it to me real now mike
it's just that we understand especially
if he's a different kind of new yorker
that we know
but we understand the pain you know
yeah beautiful man great champ yeah yeah
like you know coming from these
different zones like you know we came
out of brownsville
and that area is a whole different type
of energy yeah
it's different from the energy that's
than harlem with with zip
because it's smooth like highlights
all the brooklyn guys go to harlem
so that [ __ ] brooklyn [ __ ] take it uh
harlem [ __ ] make it is that
real [ __ ] that um um in that
confrontational not the the majority of
nice conversation
yeah they're smooth they're always fresh
people they're wearing fresh you brown
things they're strength you come
home let's rob this [ __ ] they set you
up doing a rob yeah
unless you zip you know everybody loves
it everybody loves
it coming coming from where we came from
we didn't have a lot so when we see
those guys with the fly [ __ ] and jewelry
and all that
that that's food
they bring that [ __ ] out man don't have
that [ __ ] in the house and look good
bring that [ __ ] out yeah you know what
i'm saying that was food only very few
people
in the neighborhood i always wanted to
be like when i was a little kid i
remember i had the robin hood hat
and um a guy who became my friend he
died now but
he just took my hat and punched me in my
face wow what was that about
and that's in all my life my brother
became a brain surgeon and stuff
i became a street [ __ ] ain't that
something
it's got that life just suck you and
it's just like um
being someone that's a young um guys
upcoming fighter you just want to be in
that life
life i don't even i don't know how to
even explain it then
once i got locked up i went to spartan i
saw all the people from my neighborhood
in my blocking here who i thought
disappeared to move somewhere they were
all locked up
it was like being home last year to me
i've been locked up so much when i was a
kid because it was all my friends
was there no one's gonna kill me and
nothing it's just
i don't know so that [ __ ] about
boxing the boxing business is worser
than the streets
the boxing business is worser than the
street it used to be
not anymore not now fighters are so much
more enterprising
than we were yeah devon yeah
i mean yeah 21 years old 22 years old
and
rolling 22 years old my ego you're
sucking absorbed me
i couldn't even make the right decision
i don't think mom
my conscience was my dick at 22.
brother when you came over there to the
gym and you said
fighters are prostitutes and you said it
in las vegas
i said oh [ __ ] i said devin did you say
what the [ __ ] he said
and see things like that you don't
understand we hang on to them
you know and people around the world we
hang on to your words man because
you mean so much to us
the guy comes from our community we
think we're going to a guy that's going
to
you know do the right thing so we go to
the best deal
until we realize because we don't know
our worst until we realize um
we are we are the deal that's right you
know why we got to go for the best that
we are the deal the bet everybody should
be coming to me
right you know i was tell when i was
explaining that um
mr garcia ryan he didn't want to he
didn't want to
look at it he didn't want to confront
the fact that um
he should be proud that he brought his
brother a house
those are the things that fighters
should be proud of not that they're
great fighters that's not going to last
forever
he's not going to be a fighter for too
long right you know it's about this is
the platform now you have this platform
now what do you have to take advantage
of it was definitely
the platform that's what fighting is for
the platform
to the next level of life
having fame and fortune now what's one
of the biggest things you bought
to this day that make you the happiest
that makes you the happiest
that make me the happiest um i hadn't
bought a lot of [ __ ]
i'm gonna be honest that make me the
happiest
that's a good question i don't know i
didn't bought a lot
i didn't bought a lot of stuff for other
people um just make me happy to even
have it to give you know have it to to
buy stuff to have it to
to be able to buy other people's stuff i
can't say i can't pinpoint on one thing
that made me the happiest but
i bought a lot of stuff that make me
happy yeah
happiness is not happiness is not um
happiness is in the moment life is in
the moment
that's good and then when you when you
look at it from him and i'm i'm watching
and i'm saying to what makes them happy
and when you identify
with one thing then it's over with you
know and then
then it's like okay a car makes you
happy or a house makes you happy
right then it's it's over with your
happiness is over when you got the car
but for him
to say that a lot of things make him
happy and it's not one thing and he's
just happy and he's happy to have it
to give i mean i think that's uh not me
and happy like to have a gift
like when you see it you're like wow i'm
happy that i did the had that i got that
gift for whatever whatever's for you
like wow look i did that
yeah you know what i'm saying that's
what i mean i didn't mean like you know
i'm president
yeah no i know exactly what you meant
but like i said it's just
it's a lot i know a lot um
and i'm happy i'm happy most important
i'm happy that i have it to
to be able to buy to be able to buy
stuff to be able to give cheap
to be able to you know give back to to
my people or
my people can rely on me and believe in
me that if they need something or if
they had a rainy day or something like
that then they could come to me and
and i and i know that i that i'll have
it for him
i was in the dl store and i was trying
to buy a shirt or something right so i'm
talking like she's like yeah
well let me get them let me see that
[ __ ] right there that [ __ ] is nice oh
definitely got that
like let me see those fans yeah devin
got that
you got a pirate yeah hey but the the
young girl in the store she ain't got
every everything in the deal stuff
that's crazy hey but you know what
though and and
we definitely need to let parents and
kids
that that do grow up that didn't grow up
let's say like you or or like me that
grew up with an opportunity to do to
chase their dreams that they don't lose
focus
[ __ ] around with them knuckleheads
that don't have fathers in the house
that don't have
mothers in the house that don't have
people that really care for them
and they listen to the streets that
[ __ ] in the streets that little
you know uh be down with me for a minute
turns into a whole lifetime
hey you know what i'm saying all right
so yeah i was nothing
until i saw mohammed ali and sparfit
what's the [ __ ]
that 11 into a [ __ ] blew my mind
right
mama ali what smart he's in jail oh okay
children's jail oh you were in the
children's jail and he just came to
visit him
oh mike tyson yeah blew my mind
homicide was there too how much i was
there we were all
kids 78 i was just i was what one years
old
i wasn't born yet 78 i wanted next year
crazy wow i saw a picture with you and
you and floyd when he was when he was
young when when you came to vegas what
what age was
was he and when did you notice stuff
that he was like
like uh that [ __ ] like like once
you know that he was special
he always had confidence you know he
just always had come but one day i was
in um
maybe it was cleveland i was at the
national golden gloves the national
championships whatever
and he said mr tyson is very humble mr
tyson will you please
watch me fight and he really looked um
real good i just knew him from his uncle
and his father and stuff
and his grandfather cut my hair once
from
in hudson new york you see you knew
right then that he was going to be
no no i knew his family before i knew he
even existed oh okay
i knew his uncle but the first time you
saw him did you know that he was going
to be great
my son fight professional and on amateur
as an amateur i only saw him fight
that once that time the nationals and he
won
but as a professional um his uncle roger
kept saying hey man
this guy's better than me he's clocking
me
that's just where he stays in the gym
you know that reminds me of me because
he just stays and even when he's not he
has little see
he's not he's in the gym right now what
time he's in the gym
yeah even if he's not trained he's in
the his whole life is styled in the gym
if they got
homeboy they got girl their part is in
the gym
he has everything the gym is our life
whatever you do that those four
circles are there is involved with this
mentality you ever seen somebody just
been in the gym and it didn't work out
for them
somebody yeah that had the gym that just
jim rats
yeah it didn't work what what was the
reason why i didn't then
who was the person why why it didn't
work because he was met
he was meant to teach people
[Music]
everyone have different roles he's not
nothing
right nobody's nothing
they just don't know what they're
supposed to do yet
hmm that's deep kevin haney yeah
thank y'all for he's very humble and
kind and nice and that's
and giving and that's the sign of a
killer in boxing
he's very kind and like un you know i
mean
what else would he pay me for now you
heard what he said t ho
come on out the woodwork and let's make
a real
that's mr lopez these [ __ ] ain't going
to give you
a world champion that's what we need to
do ryan garcia
come out the bushes out to bushes and
you do what
mike tyson did and you do what zap judah
did they seized the opportunity when
they was mandatory
you you knock it off now you said you
the king
and we're in la right now there you have
it here i'm hot boxing
i'm zap judah bill haney trainer father
to the number one fighter in the whole
world devin haney
the number one fighter in the world
devin the dream haney
and i'm mike tyson and i didn't say
nothing bad to mr
elfield
now we're gonna play it back and we're
gonna run it back five or ten ten
million times for you
don't worry about it mike you have been
up you have been a blessing you are a
god
you you're a god to us and he said t ho
come on
and ryan garcia you heard what he said
tank davis now what do you think about
tank
should we make well you said tank needs
to talk to make the fighter should tank
talk to devon and then make it happen
or is that a fight you want to see well
listen i would like to say yeah i'd like
to see devin fight all those guys
all of them yeah i like seeing them
fight all right i like seeing him fight
stevenson but steven i'm too low right
and wait
yeah yeah too little right now well see
we'll see when you talk about stevenson
now you want
you want the whole world to vibrate when
devin haney and
and shakur stevens it's going to be the
biggest event
he's going to tell you he's going to be
in there i know it's what i ask
right now well now we talk about the
future but but can we say now
because we're tired of talking about
next we're confusing well you should
just say well you just said who wants to
fight me you should say who wants to
fight me
right now say who wants to fight me
because you got
hundreds of millions who want to fight
the number one fighter in the world at
135 pounds
we wait heaven we waiting the dream hey
tell him this so you're the greatest
fighter god ever created
i'm the greatest i'm the greatest
fighter god ever created
um y'all see
they'll see real soon the world will
know
that's it thank you brother
[Music]
you